le soleil est actuellement dans une
intense période d'activité qui provoque
la formation de nombreuses et puissantes
tempêtes solaires celle qui s'est formé
lundi dernier est en train de frapper la
terre avec des ventes particules
radioactives qui se déplace à plus de
500 kilomètres à la seconde le soleil
notre étoile c'est une immense boule de
gaz et à l'occasion il ya des éruptions
de matières qui quitte la surface et la
couronne solaire et qui voyage à travers
le système solaire la tempête d'abord
considéré d'importance majeure par les
experts a été rétrogradé aujourd'hui à
modéré ce qui signifie qu'on devrait
éviter de subir des pannes majeures sur
les réseaux électriques et internet au
sol mais également des bris dans
l'espace ça peut affecter toute la
quincaillerie électroniques électriques
et électroniques dont on dispose or on
parle de satellites en orbite autour de
la terre météo communication gps les
astronautes dans la station spatiale
internationale
en contrepartie si on prévoit que cette
tempête va créer une immense zone
propice à la formation d'aurores
boréales très coloré présentement ce
constat c'est qu'on puisse les voir plus
facilement au sud ça devrait même se
rendre propre possiblement jusque dans
les états comme la pennsylvanie au sud
de la frontière donc on devrait assister
à un spectacle assez impressionnant déjà
des horreurs spectaculaires comme celles
ci ont été observées en castille
mais également en basse côte nord et si
la température est clémente et le ciel
clair même les montréalais pourraient en
profiter dans les prochains jours ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal